[Musique]
ils ont rarement été aussi heureux
d'être sur scène ce n'est que la
répétition mais ils mettent toutes leurs
passions
[Musique]
le légendaire opéra de dessin à rouvert
cet été porté par un nouvel élan sous la
direction artistique d'oxane
la pièce vient de s'ajouter au programme
inspiré d'un grand poète ukrainien
russe tous les classiques ont été
retirés des spectacles
en fait pour tous les artistes c'est le
bouclier le plus puissant contre la
terreur qu'on leur inflige depuis des
mois
et c'est un geste de défiance dans cette
ville russophone fondée au 18e siècle
par l'impératrice Catherine II dont la
statue de bronze n'est plus du tout la
bienvenue car Vladimir Poutine a
toujours considéré un destin comme
partie intégrante de la nouvelle Russie
qu'il veut bâtir et la statue demeure un
symbole de la pression russe 17
historiens
elle reniait les frontières et voulait
redessiner la carte de l'Europe comme
lui
ça fait des mois que des ça appréhendent
d'une attaque majeure ou même un
débarquement des troubles du Kremlin
les monuments qui font de décès le joyau
architectural de l'Ukraine sont
interdits d'accès ou protégés mais les
sacs de sable n'enlèvent rien à la
splendeur de la façade baroque du Grand
Opéra
sa femme et leur fils viennent tout
juste de rentrer à un dessin après six
mois d'exil dans l'ouest du pays
cette peur constante d'être l'ultime de
l'invasion russe
car redesca n'est pas qu'un port
stratégique et la porte d'entrée sur la
mer Noire elle est le symbole de tout ce
que Vladimir Poutine veut détruire bien
ça
une ville où les cultures se marient où
chaque coin de rue témoigne de sa
diversité et de son ouverture
vu la 150 km du front mais où les jeunes
ne se laissent pas abattre par la peur
juste avant le couvre-feu presque tous
les soirs de ça des humoristes se fait
la tête de l'ennemi bonjour
les fonds amassés serviront à acheter
des véhicules pour les soldats qui se
battent pour eux
[Musique]
et lui aussi ne le fait plus qu'en
ukrainien
je trouve que au contraire c'est tout
paisible tout le monde y sont bien
accueillants dans cette touriste
françaises a dit à sa famille qu'elle
partait en vacances à ça on lui a dit
qu'elle était complètement folle on dit
comme ça qu'il risque pas il boit pas
champagne le risque on va aller la peine
pourtant de beauté mais pour ceux qui
restent l'avenir demeure incertain
même plus le droit de planifier des
spectacles ou de la du prochain mot
du Tamara Alteresco Radio-Canada au
destin